[Música]
aquí comienza a ella soy de france24 la
corte suprema de eeuu podría legalizar
el aborto en la noche del lunes 2 de
mayo el portal de noticias político
filtró un borrador sobre la postura
mayoritaria en el alto tribunal a favor
de retroceder en el que hasta ahora ha
sido considerado un derecho en el país
de emitirse el fallo anularía roe versus
wait la decisión histórica que se firmó
en
1973 en un caso histórico y que
estableció a nivel federal el derecho
constitucional y privado para
interrumpir el embarazo qué pasaría si
el supremo anula el roe versus wade y si
el aborto queda en manos de los estados
vamos a conversar sobre este tema con
una experta pero antes de veamos el
siguiente informe
en varias ciudades de eeuu los
manifestantes se tomaron las calles
indignados su ira dirigida a la corte
suprema tras la filtración del borrador
de una opinión que sugería que el órgano
judicial estaría a punto de anular el
fallo histórico de roe versus way de
1973 que estableció el aborto como un
derecho constitucional da miedo es
devastador pero definitivamente estoy
motivada para seguir luchando y nos
aseguraremos de que el acceso al aborto
permanezca no se trata sólo del aborto
se trata del control y ahora estamos
viendo que el control se nos va y no lo
que oramos mientras estos manifestantes
luchan para que se mantengan los
derechos de las mujeres a decidir
algunos estados ya se están preparando
para una nueva era si se anulara el
fallo histórico el derecho a interrumpir
el embarazo se dejaría en manos de los
legisladores estatales y los líderes de
estados conservadores ya están listos
para convocar a sesiones legislativas
especiales para prohibir el
procedimiento si el tribunal supremo
revoca la sentencia el gobernador de
oklahoma firmó un proyecto de ley que
prohíbe el aborto después de seis
semanas coincidiendo con una ley similar
en texas gobernadores demócratas en
estados como california anunciaron
rápidamente planes para consagrar el
derecho al aborto en la ley local un
movimiento alentado por el presidente de
byd en su administración pide a la corte
suprema que proteja el acceso al aborto
como se atreven a decirle a una mujer lo
que puede y no puede hacer con su propio
cuerpo como se atreven a tratar de
evitar que determine su propio futuro
como se atreven a negar a las mujeres
sus derechos y libertades
el borrador no es una sentencia
definitiva por lo tanto no es seguro que
se revierta la histórica decisión a
pesar de una mayoría conservadora en la
corte suprema- una encuesta del
washington post y el vice news encontró
que sólo el 28 por ciento de los
estadounidenses cree que la decisión de
1973 debería ser anulada
y la conversaciones sobre el tema es con
johan y adam es ella es directora de
comunicaciones de latino víctor y
project trabajo en planned parenthood y
ahora es también estratega política
johan y bienvenida a ella soy qué
pasaría si se anulara roe versus wade y
qué consecuencias habría si cada estado
tuviera en sus manos la decisión del
aborto
bueno un placer estar contigo angela va
a ser devastador si llegase a suceder
que la corte suprema anule el caso de
robbie whale esto va a desencadenar un
sinnúmero de leyes estatales hay que
recordar que eeuu tiene 50 estados y
cada estado que regula el aborto
de acuerdo a lo que su legislatura
estatal considere entonces estamos
hablando de en estados más conservadores
el aborto va a ser ilegal en muchos
casos se espera que automáticamente
entre en vigencia leyes ya firmadas por
gobernadores en estado conservadores en
casi 13 de ellos donde el aborto va a
ser anulado por completo y en otros
estados más o menos 26 donde el aborto
va a ser restringido entonces estamos
hablando que la mitad de eeuu se va a
quedar sin acceso al aborto seguro y
legal bueno y entendiendo que los
demócratas han abogado mucho por
proteger este derecho basándose también
en el derecho a la privacidad de las
mujeres johan y porque estaría en
peligro ese derecho a la privacidad y
por qué es factible para esta corte
conservadora cambiar el fallo
entendiendo que el aborto no aparece
explícitamente en la constitución como
un derecho el derecho al aborto no
aparece en la constitución de la misma
manera que las mujeres y muchos de los
derechos que nosotros tenemos en este
país no aparecen bajo la constitución en
ninguna de las enmiendas eso no fue la y
la idea original de los fundadores de
este país por eso la corte juega un
papel tan importante porque la corte al
pasar los años
redefine cuáles son los derechos
cualquier es legal y que no es legal que
se ampara bajo la constitución y esa era
la idea original que sea un documento
vivo que sea un documento que se analice
nuevamente entonces a la corte decidir
es fallar en su propia contra como quien
dice si es cierto que ese borrador es el
fallo final que veremos en junio la
corte se está contradiciendo a sí misma
eso nunca se había visto desde el punto
de vista que la corte quite de derechos
la corte cuando se contrae cuando se
contrae y decide cambiar algo en la
constitución es para agregar más
derechos a las personas no para lo
contrario entonces es algo sin
precedentes nunca habíamos visto algo
lo que sucedió la noche del lunes y eso
va a desencadenar una cadena de
casos legales que van a llegar a la
corte suprema- particularmente los casos
que están amparados bajo la enmienda 14
bueno pero es que también esto se dio
bajo una situación particular porque hoy
en día tenemos una corte suprema- con
una mayoría conservadora después de que
en el mandato anterior donald trump tuvo
la oportunidad de nombrar dos jueces
ambos de corte conservador estamos en un
balance de seis a tres y diciendo esto
le pregunto porque avanza tanto esta
tendencia en eeuu hacia la prohibición
pese haber legislado a favor en los 70
esto sucede en la corte suprema pero
además ya vimos que están avanzando en
restricciones en varios estados
republicanos como se relaciona todo
es un plan estratégico que llevan los
conservadores y los republicanos de hace
décadas desde que la corte suprema
decidió legalizar el derecho al aborto a
nivel nacional y hay que recordar que lo
que la corte suprema hizo fue definir el
derecho al aborto bajo la enmienda 14 en
estados unidos legalmente no se ha
legislado lo que significa que el
congreso de eeuu no ha codificado el
derecho al aborto por eso es que cada
estado puede definir qué es cuántas
semanas por ejemplo se puede se puede se
puede terminar un embarazo se puede
interrumpir un embarazo y también qué
tipos de leyes pueden existir para que
un centro de salud una clínica pueda
funcionar y para que los médicos y los
proveedores de aborto puedan ejercer y
brindar ese servicio entonces por eso
tiene 50 estados 50 leyes diferentes que
varían y eso crean un caos total y lo
que hemos visto es que es un plan
estratégico de los conservadores de los
republicanos desde hace décadas y de
cara a las elecciones de medio término
pero ahora quiero preguntarles sobre la
gente que cambia con esta prohibición
habrá menos abortos y qué es
argumentarían los ciudadanos que se
dicen pro-vida a quien les afectaría a
la nueva normativa o las nuevas
normativas estatales
bueno que lo adulto esté anulado en la
corte suprema no significa que el aborto
se convierta inmediatamente ilegal en
todo eeuu lo que va a suceder es que va
a regresar a los estados y la gente va a
tener que a
de acuerdo a lo que su estado diga
entonces estamos creando un sistema un
caos legal donde si vives en la florida
aplica una ley diferente a si vives en
el estado de nueva york entonces eso va
a crear que tus derechos se van se
cambien de acuerdo cuando cruzas la
línea de un estado a otro y más del 80%
de la población está en contra de que se
anule el broadway particularmente la
comunidad latina en eeuu más del 55 por
ciento dice que no está de acuerdo con
que el aborto aunque se prohíba la ley o
se anule la ley de robbie wait entonces
esto se va a llevar si llegase a suceder
que el aborto se anule por como repito
es un borrador pueden cambiar de opinión
los jueces de aquí al término a cuando
termine la sesión de la corte suprema en
junio si llegase a suceder va a ser un
caso en las elecciones vamos a tener que
ver en las urnas lo que las personas
deciden si las personas van a votar por
políticos conservadores políticos que
van a restringir su acceso al aborto que
van a restringir y van a continuar
quitando los derechos que eso nunca
había sucedido la historia de eeuu
mire está demostrado que no solamente en
eeuu sino alrededor del mundo las
mujeres más afectadas por las
restricciones de aborto son las mujeres
que no tienen recursos las mujeres que
tienen dificultad para acceder a los
servicios de salud y que son además en
general poblaciones vulnerables en
víctimas de abuso sexual víctimas de
circunstancias que no les permiten
digamos llevar a cabo un embarazo o al
menos un embarazo planeado y deseado que
sería la condición ideal
ahora quisiera preguntarle para contexto
de nuestros televidentes ya cuando vamos
llegando hacia el final del programa
hagamos un breve resumen de lo que ha
sido este caso histórico el roe versus
way que fue tan famoso en eeuu y que
hizo que la corte constitucional en su
momento tomará una decisión que para los
años 70 era sumamente progresista
correcto el impacto que va a tener
particularmente va a ser en comunidades
en grupos minoritarios en grupos en
personas de mujeres negras mujeres
latinas que no tienen acceso que no van
a tener los recursos para ir a un estado
donde el aborto sea más flexible el año
pasado vimos cuando el estado de texas
promulgó la ley de seis semanas que
cientos de mujeres se desplazaron a
otros estados para hacerse para poder
acceder a un aborto después de seis
semanas y eso no es algo que va a ser
posible para muchas especialmente para
mujeres de bajos recursos que viven en
este país entonces estamos hablando que
la ley va a aplicar que va a relegar a
la mujer particularmente a la mujer
pobre a la mujer que no tiene acceso a
cuidado de salud a ciudadanas de segunda
categoría y eso es lo que hace ese tipo
de ley ese tipo de ley en busca de
causar el trauma a causar estragos en la
vida de personas que ya están
enfrentando barreras para acceder a
cuidados de salud o atención médica en
este país pues johan y muchísimas
gracias a usted por el contexto que nos
da en este caso de todas claro que hay
que aclararlo no hay una decisión tomada
todavía la estamos esperando para
mediados de este año y estaremos atentos
al desarrollo y sobre todo a las
implicaciones que tendría un cambio o
una ilegalización y anulación del fallo
roe versus web gracias a usted por estar
con nosotros y a nuestros televidentes
que sigan en france24 nos vemos
próximamente en ellas hoy
[Música]